Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. It is the 3rd of January. It is the latest in our series on the 12 days of Christmas, or 13 days, which is what we're doing. And we're doing anniversaries every day. Tom chooses one, I choose one. And Tom, you're going to go first today, aren't you, with a man who I think is very close to your heart. Yes. Well, featured in one of the very earliest episodes that we did on the idea of social media echoing the way that printing and the new media had been used in the Reformation. And of course, the absolute master of that was Martin Luther, the man who is often seen as the father of the record of the
感谢您收听《历史其余部分》。想要每周获取独家播客、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 加入我们。今天是1月3日。这是我们关于圣诞节12天（或者如我们所做的那样，13天）系列的最新一期。每天都有一个纪念日。汤姆选一个，我选一个。汤姆，今天你先来吧，选一个我想对你来说非常重要的人。是的。确实如此。在我们早期的一集节目中曾重点介绍过，当时探讨了社交媒体如何呼应印刷术和新媒体在宗教改革中的运用。当然，那个领域的绝对大师就是马丁·路德，他通常被视为
reformation um and yesterday dominic we had um the uh the fateful year that saw the the conquest of granada uh columbus the expulsion of the jews from spain one of the kind of key dates as you said for you know this is the end point of the middle ages yeah and another obvious um date would be um the early 1520s when martin luther really gets the reformation going and possibly the key moment in that the moment that marks the kind of the point where the schism is formalized is when luther gets exicated, officially excommunicated, cast out from the Catholic church by the Pope. And that happened on the 3rd of January, 1521. So Tom set the scene for us. So I think it's 1517, isn't it? That Martin Luther famously nails,
宗教改革的……嗯，昨天多米尼克，我们谈到了……嗯，那个命运般的年份，见证了格拉纳达的征服、哥伦布远航、将犹太人驱逐出西班牙，正如你所说，这是中世纪终结的关键节点之一。是的，另一个显而易见的年份是……16世纪20年代初，马丁·路德真正掀起宗教改革的时候，其中可能最关键的时刻，标志着宗教改革正式分裂的时刻，是路德被教皇正式开除教籍、逐出天主教会。这发生在1521年1月3日。所以，汤姆，请为我们梳理一下背景。我想那是1517年吧，马丁·路德轰轰烈烈地将他的……
or in fact, probably doesn't nail his 95 theses to the door of that church in Wittenberg. And that's the moment that's commonly seen as sort of kickstarting the Protestant Reformation. So this is four years after that. And what's been happening in that kind of, I mean, what's the backstory to all this? Well, so essentially, Luther has all kinds of issues that are theological and doctrinal, and they increasingly strike at the very heart of the great kind of edifice of doctrine that the Catholic Church and specifically the papacy kind of exists to uphold. And the question is, that has always confronted the Catholic Church throughout the Middle Ages, whenever confronted by, you know, heretical movements, is what do you do with them?
或者实际上，可能并没有将他的《九十五条论纲》钉在维滕贝格那座教堂的大门上。那是通常被视为新教宗教改革导火索的时刻。所以这是四年之后。那么在那期间发生了什么？也就是说，这一切的背景是什么？嗯，基本上，路德提出了各种神学和教义上的问题，这些问题越来越直击天主教会乃至教宗制度所极力维护的宏大教义大厦的核心。问题在于，中世纪以来天主教会每当面对异端运动时，总是会面临一个问题：你该拿他们怎么办？
Do you try and kind of integrate them into the fabric of the church? Or do you kind of expel them and try and extirpate them? And there are kind of various strategies that are adopted in the years that immediately follow Luther's kind of, you know, pronouncement, his nailing of the theses. So there's a cardinal, Cardinal Catterhan, who comes and attempts to negotiate with Luther directly, but Luther isn't really having any of it. And when Luther turns his back on Catterhan, goes back to Wittenberg, which is under the rule of the elector Friedrich of Saxony, who is very proud of Luther. You know, Luther's made himself the most famous person in Europe. Wittenberg has become this kind of great center of, you know, it's the focus of attention across Christendom. So in a sense, Luther is kind of safe there, out beyond the reach of the papacy.
你是试图将他们融入教会的结构中？还是将他们驱逐并试图根除？在路德发表论纲、表明立场之后的几年里，采取了各种不同的策略。有一位红衣主教，卡耶坦枢机，前来试图与路德直接谈判，但路德并不买账。当路德背对卡耶坦，回到萨克森选帝侯腓特烈统治下的维滕贝格时，腓特烈对路德感到非常骄傲。你知道，路德让自己成了全欧洲最著名的人。维滕贝格已经成了这样一个伟大的中心……它是全基督教世界关注的焦点。所以从某种意义上说，路德在那里是安全的，超出了教宗权力的触及范围。
Basically, Luther has decided that, you know, it's beyond the point of no return. It's on the 15th of June in 1520 that the Pope, who is Leo X, he issues a pap papal bull which protestants always find a very amusing yeah but you know it's an official papal announcement um in which he warns luther that you know he is going to be excommunicated unless he retracts all kinds of um heretical statements um you know excommunication is is absolutely happening um and this bull is called Ex Sergei Domine, Arise, O Lord. It gets issued in the summer of 1520. On the 10th of December, Luther has a copy of it, and he very, very publicly, very symbolically burns it.
基本上，路德已经认定，事情已经到了无可挽回的地步。在1520年6月15日，时任教皇利奥十世发布了一道教宗诏书（新教徒总是觉得这个词很有趣，是的），但这是一份官方的教宗公告，他在其中警告路德，除非他收回各种异端言论，否则他将被开除教籍……你知道，开除教籍是绝对会发生的。这份诏书被称为《主啊，奋起吧》（Exsurge Domine）。它于1520年夏天发布。12月10日，路德拿到了一份副本，并非常公开、非常象征性地将它烧毁了。
Yeah, doesn't he? It's this great public spectacle, isn't it? He puts it in the fire he's not shouting about antichrist or something there's always a lot of shouting about antichrist he he goes to one of the three city gates of wittenberg and there's it's a kind of carrion pit it's where um people burn uh kind of old clothing it's it's a place where you get rid of rubbish right it's like basically the municipal tip it's a municipal tip yes exactly and um he's got he's gone he's gone rushing around all the libraries of wittenberg uh trying to get out uh books of canon law which is the uh you know the law that
是的，不是吗？这是一场宏大的公开奇观，对吧？他把它扔进火里，他当时不是在喊“敌基督”或者别的什么吗？总是有很多关于“敌基督”的呐喊。他走到维滕贝格三个城门中的一个，那里有点像一个腐尸坑，是人们焚烧旧衣服的地方，是个处理垃圾的地方。基本上就像是市政垃圾场，没错，就是市政垃圾场。而且……他跑遍了维滕贝格所有的图书馆，试图找出教会法典的书籍，也就是……嗯，那种专门适用于教会的法律，然后他把它们堆成一堆，扔进火里，把威胁要开除他教籍的教宗诏书《主啊，奋起吧》也一起扔进了火里。是的，有很多……你知道，他称教皇为敌基督，诸如此类的话。他是在自招开除教籍。他想要这个结果。果不其然，他得到了。他在今天得到了这个结果。但是，汤姆，我知道这是一个极其宏大的主题。
specifically applies um to to the church and he piles them up and he chucks them on the fire and he chucks ex-sergey domine this papal bull that's threatening him with excommunication, on the fire as well. And yeah, there's a lot of, you know, he calls the Pope Antichrist, all that kind of stuff. You know, he's courting excommunication. He wants it. And sure enough, that's what he gets. And that's what he gets on this day. But Tom, I know this is a colossal topic.
他的动机是什么？他认为自己在行使上帝的旨意。没错。在1517年之前，是什么改变了他？哦，多米尼克，你能用一句话回答这个问题吗？我想，宗教改革的基石、对天主教会权威的核心挑战，就是路德的观点：
What's his motive? He thinks he's doing God's will. Right. And what has converted him prior to 1517? Oh, Dominic. Are you able to answer that in one sentence? I suppose the kind of the bedrock of the Reformation, the central challenge to the authority of the Catholic Church is Luther's idea.
你不需要教会的上层建筑来为你提供救赎，救赎是上帝的恩赐。因此，这是你与上帝的个人关系。这是你与圣灵的个人关系。这是你与经文的个人关系，它应该、应该决定你作为基督徒的行为。所以这就是为什么他要烧毁教会法典的书籍，因为他开始看到……
You don't need the superstructure of the church to provide you with salvation, that that is God's gift. And that therefore it's your personal relationship with God. It's your personal relationship with the spirit. It's your personal relationship with scripture that should, that should determine your behavior as a Christian. And that all, so this is why he burns the books of, of canon law is that he comes to see the claims of the,
天主教会声称……也就是说，除了通过天主教会、在教宗制度的支持下之外，别无救赎。正因为如此，他开始将天主教会视为对基督教教义的一种骇人听闻的扭曲，这也是为什么他将教皇的形象——不是指具体的某位教皇，而是指教宗制度本身——本质上视为敌基督。而且，毫无疑问，按照天主教会的标准，路德完全罪有应得，理当被开除教籍。所以这其中……可以说是……绝对的……
the Catholic church to embody, you know, that there is no salvation except through um through through the catholic church underpinned by the papacy and that's why he comes to see the catholic church as a kind of monstrous distortion of christian teaching and it's why he sees the figure of the pope so not the individual popes but the you know the papacy as essentially antichrist um and you know there is no question that by the standards of the catholic church luther entirely merits excommunication um so i there's there's there's kind of you know there's there's absolute you know
几十个、二十个、三十个、四十个、五十个，你可以列举很多：将因义与圣化分离、外在的法庭式的归算义、凭信心称义、个人的私人判断对抗教会的无谬性、拒绝七卷次经、否认轻罪、否认功德、唯独圣经（所以只有圣经，而不是天主教会的法典）、激进的私人判断——如果我们都是祭司，为什么我们不能也有权在信仰问题上检验和判断什么是对是错？——否认教皇拥有训导权、只有被称义的人才能行善。我的意思是，这些都是……所以我不会把它们全部过一遍，
tens 20 30 40 50 you can just kind of so separation of justification from sanctification extrinsic forensic imputed justification for deutery faith private judgment over against ecclesiastical infallibility the rejection of the seven deuterocanonical books the denial of venial sin the denial of merit sola scriptura so you know only only scripture not the kind of the canons of the catholic church radically private judgment if we're all priests why should we not also have the power to test and judge what is right or wrong in matters of faith denial that the pope has the right to counsel only justified men can do good works i mean these are so i won't go through them
我确信听众听到这里会松一口气。但本质上，这些是对天主教会构建的一切的系统性攻击，不仅是在中世纪的过程中，在许多情况下，也包括在晚期古代时期。这就是为什么它是如此震撼人心。它引发了旷日持久、延续至今的深刻分裂。而且，你知道，这是基督徒们继续梦想弥合的分裂。不过，这不会发生，对吧？嗯，两年前，即2020年，有一群神学家属于一个叫做“阿尔滕堡大公会议圆桌会议”的组织，该组织成立于1999年左右吧……他们知道周年纪念日即将到来，所以他们说，为什么不进行某种“对等交换”呢？这样教皇基本上撤销开除教籍的决定，而世界路德宗联合会也会进行某种对等交换，这样教皇基本上撤销开除教籍的决定，而世界路德宗联合会也会同意教皇并非敌基督
all i'm sure listeners will be relieved to hear. But essentially, these are systematic attacks on everything that the Catholic Church has constructed, not just over the course of the Middle Ages, but in many cases over the period of late antiquity as well. And so this is why it is so seismic. And it's generated this profound schism that endures to this day. And, you know, it's one that Christians continue to dream of healing. That's not going to happen, though, is it? Well, so two years ago, in 2020, there was a group of theologians who belonged to something called the Altenburg Ecumenical Roundtable, which'd been founded back i think 1999 something like that um and they they knew that the uh the anniversary was coming up yeah so um they they said uh what about kind of quid pro quo so that the pope would essentially withdraw this communication and the lutheran world federation would kind of quid pro quo so that the pope would essentially withdraw this communication and the lutheran world federation would kind of agree that the pope wasn't the antichrist
哇，你知道，这难道不是一种……一种很好的对等交换吗？这对路德宗来说是一个巨大的让步，对吧？我的意思是，据我所了解，世界路德宗联合会无权以这种方式代表路德宗发言。当然，他们都是新教徒，所以这一切……是的，所以你们都在运用你们个人的判断。是的，运用你们自己的个人判断，完全正确。所以这可以说是问题所在。但这显然没有发生。没有。
and wow you know wouldn't this be wouldn't this be a kind of you know a good quid pro quo that's a big concession from the lutherans right i mean well i i gather um that that the lutheran world federation doesn't have the right to speak for lutherans in this way Of course, they're all Protestants, so that's all, you know. Yeah, so you're all using your individual judgment. Yeah, use your own individual judgment, exactly. So that's kind of the problem. But that obviously hasn't happened. No.
我的意思是，我认为确实有关于这方面的讨论。我们在2016年去德国度假，也就是在维滕贝格钉（或未钉）论纲周年纪念的前一年，他们在售卖——我们也买了一个——马丁·路德的摩比世界（Playmobil）玩偶。是的，我认为那是德国最畅销的摩比世界玩偶，真的吗？我想是的，诸如此类很不寻常的事情。所以摩比世界在德国相当受欢迎，因为它是德国的品牌。因此纽伦堡外面有一个摩比世界主题公园，我们去过那里。我们买了一个马丁·路德和阿尔布雷希特·丢勒的玩偶，
I mean, I think there is kind of talk about it. We went to Germany on holiday in 2016, so the year before the anniversary of the nailing or the non-nailing of the theses in in wittenberg and they were selling and we bought a playmobil figure of martin yes i think the best-selling playmobil figure in germany of all really i think so something extraordinary like that so playmobil is quite a big deal in germany because it is german so there was a playmobil park outside nuremberg, which we've been to. And we bought Martin Luther and Albrecht Durer,
丢勒也是一个摩比世界玩偶。好吧，我知道马丁·路德的摩比世界玩偶卖得极其好。他是一个伟大的角色。我们过去常常在战斗中使用他。我过去常常用我儿子的摩比世界和乐高玩偶组织战斗，其中马丁·路德会领导一支庞大的新教军队，里面夹杂着一些达世机（Daleks）和星球大战
who also is a Playmobil figure. Well, I know that the Martin Luther Playmobil character sold incredibly well. He's a great figure. We used to use him in battles. I used to arrange battles with my son's Playmobil and Lego figures in which Martin Luther would be leading a huge army of Protestants with sort of Daleks in it and Star Wars
帝国冲锋队员。他有教皇吗？对抗教皇的军队，是的。我会让星球大战里的皇帝来扮演教皇。好吧，多米尼克。这带有相当强的倾向性。
Stormtroopers. Did he have a Pope? Against the armies of the Pope, yeah. I'd get the Emperor from Star Wars to be the Pope. Well, Dominic. It was quite loaded.
这是一个相当具有新教色彩的游戏。它相当有倾向性。是的。这是一个非常爱国游戏。那是非常具有英格兰中部特色的一项活动。是的，完全如此。我想大多数听众会认为这完全合情合理，
It was quite a Protestant game. It's quite loaded. Yeah. It's a very patriotic game. That's a very Middle English thing to be doing. Yeah, exactly. I think most of the listeners will think that completely reasonable,
而且他们可能也有类似的故事要讲。可能我们会失去所有的天主教听众。对此我深表歉意。好吧，接下来我们有一段精彩的天主教内容，不是吗？我们确实有一段精彩的……我们有一位优秀的天主教人物，不是吗？我们有的。一位优秀的天主教作家。顶级的天主教徒。
and probably they've got similar stories to tell them. And probably we lose all our Catholic listeners. I apologise for that. Well, we've got a great bit of Catholicism coming up, haven't we? We do have a great, we've got a great Catholic, haven't we? We have. A great Catholic writer. A top Catholic.
顶级的天主教徒。你在《Unheard》杂志上写过他。而我刻意完全没有提到他的天主教信仰。我当时生气了吗？纯粹出于宣传的目的。你当时生气了。是的，你生气了。好吧，你当时生气了，但我想你同时也有点觉得好笑。
A top Catholic. Who you wrote about in Unheard. And I deliberately did not mention his Catholicism at all. And was I cross? Just out of propagandism. You were cross. Yeah, you were cross. Well, you were cross, but I think you were a little bit amused at the same time.
嗯，我想……是的。所以我想托尔金，生于今天——是的，多米尼克的选择——平衡了前半部分的路德基调，所以我们应该来谈谈托尔金，我们在中场休息后再来谈谈托尔金。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《历史其余部分》姊妹篇《娱乐其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的固定去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
Well, I think... Yes. So I think that Tolkien, born on this day yeah dominic's choice uh and counterbalances the the lutheran tone of the first half of this so we should come to talking let's come to talking after the break i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
如果你想享受无广告收听、独家附赠节目以及抢先购买现场演出门票的特权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到我们今天的新教与天主教主题特别节目。我们在前半部分讲述了路德被开除教籍。而在后半部分，多米尼克，今天是J·R·R·托尔金的生日。J·R·R·托尔金出生了。所以今天是他的生日。那是1892年1月3日。你知道托尔金是在哪里出生的吗，汤姆？
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to our Protestant Catholic themed special today. We've had Luther being excommunicated in the first half. And in the second half, Dominic, it's J.R.R. Tolkien's birthday. J.R.R. Tolkien being born. So it's his birthday. It's the 3rd of January, 1892. You know where Tolkien is born, Tom?
我知道。布隆方丹。是的，布隆方丹，当时属于奥兰治自由邦。所以托尔金家族……对于一个非常英国本土的作家来说，他有着相当异国情调的背景。他们是德国人，对吧？是的，他们是德国人。显然，他们最初来自……
I do. Bloemfontein. Yeah, Bloemfontein, in the Orange Free State, as it then was. So he's the Tolkien family. For a very English writer, he's got quite a sort of exotic. He's German, weren't they? Yeah, they're Germans. They're from, apparently, they originally.
托克（Toque）。所以那种托克。是的。是的。是的。你知道他们来自哪里吗？他们来自东普鲁士。我确实知道这一点，是的。所以他们现在就不算德国人了。
Full of a toque. So the kind of the toque. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So do you know where they're from? They're from East Prussia. I did know that, yeah. So they wouldn't be German now.
托克。所以那种托克。是的。是的。是的。你知道他们来自哪里吗？他们来自东普鲁士。我确实知道这一点，是的。所以他们现在就不算德国人了。
They would be kind of living in a Russian enclave. That's astonishing, isn't it? So they come from what's now Kaliningrad, but what was then Königsberg. Oh, yeah, home of Kant. And it's sort of... So his earliest known ancestor is somebody called Michel Tolkien, born around 1620.
他们有点像生活在一个俄罗斯飞地里。这太令人惊异了，不是吗？所以他们来自现在的加里宁格勒，也就是当时的柯尼斯堡。哦，对，康德的故乡。而且有点……所以他最早为人所知的祖先是一个叫米歇尔·托尔金的人，生于1620年左右。
And they were, well, they moved to sort of to England in the early modern period at some point. And they made clocks, watches, and pianos in London and Birmingham. Anyway, Arthur Tolkien, who is Tolkien's father, he was born in 1857. He was a bank manager, rather. Unexcitingly. Yes, the sword of fate.
他们，嗯，在近代早期的某个时候搬到了英格兰。他们在伦敦和伯明翰制造时钟、手表和钢琴。总之，托尔金的父亲亚瑟·托尔金出生于1857年。他其实是一位银行经理。平淡无奇。是的，命运之剑。
The ring of doom. Yeah. The bank statement of destiny. Exactly. Well, you would. I mean, that's what would fill your mind with all this stuff. It's kind of sending a bank statement, you know, a checkbook to Galadriel. So he's a bank manager and he is posted with his wife mabel to which is again a very i mean it's not so they're posted to bloom fontaine uh by the bank
厄运之戒。对。命运的银行对账单。没错。嗯，你会这么想的。我的意思是，这就是那些会让你满脑子充满这些东西的原因。这有点像给加拉德瑞尔寄一份银行对账单，你知道的，一本支票簿。所以他是一名银行经理，他和妻子梅贝尔一起被银行派往——这又是一个非常，我的意思是，他们被银行派到了布隆方丹
and he goes off to work in the bank and um tolkien is born in the on the 3rd of January 1892 and his brother, do you know what his brother's name was? No. Hilary. Hilary? Hilary. What did he become? I don't know, maybe he became a back manager as well. He didn't write a series of fantasy novels,
然后他去银行上班，嗯……托尔金出生于1892年1月3日，他的兄弟，你知道他兄弟叫什么名字吗？不知道。希拉里。希拉里？希拉里。他后来成了什么？我不知道，也许他也成了银行经理。他可没写过一系列奇幻小说，
so I think we can forget about poor old Hilary. He was born in 1894 and basically when Tolkienlkien gerar was three um they basically decided to go back to england for a big visit so his mum gets on the boat with him and his brother and off they go and his father has got some work to do so he's going to follow them later and he gets rheumatic fever i don't actually know what that is, but it's bad. It's bad. And he dies before he even gets on the boat to join them. So Tolkien never remembered his father.
所以我想我们可以把可怜的老希拉里忘了。他生于1894年，基本上当托尔金三岁时，嗯，他们基本上决定回英格兰进行一次大探亲，所以他妈妈带着他和弟弟上了船，他们出发了，而他的父亲还有一些工作要做，所以他打算随后跟上，结果他得了风湿热——其实我不知道那是什么，但很严重。很严重。而且他在上船和他们汇合之前就去世了。所以托尔金从未记住过他的父亲。
So never remembered his father. So they're in England visiting his mother's family, and they basically have to stay forever. So they end up staying in Birmingham, and they stay in a place. Well, initially, they live with her parents. And in 1896, when Tolkien is four they move to this village of Serhol and then
所以从未记住过他的父亲。因此他们当时在英格兰拜访他母亲的家族，基本上不得不永远留下来。最后他们在伯明翰住下了，住在一个地方。嗯，最初，他们和她的父母住在一起。1896年，当托尔金四岁时，他们搬到了塞霍尔这个村庄，然后
it was a village in North Worcestershire now it's basically in suburban Birmingham and you can visit the I have visited the mill which is the inspiration for the mill there's a mill and there's a bog and they're the inspiration for some of the sort of the landscapes of the Lord of the Rings.
它当时是北伍斯特郡的一个村庄，现在基本上成了伯明翰的郊区，你可以去参观——我参观过那个磨坊，那里就是磨坊的灵感来源，那里有一个磨坊，还有一个沼泽，它们都是《指环王》中某些风景的灵感来源。
Is it the Shire? Exactly. It is the Shire. And then when Birmingham kind of moves in, it's the harrowing of the Shire. Exactly. Birmingham swallows it up at exactly the moment when Tolkien is kind of a boy and then a teenager.
是夏尔吗？没错。这就是夏尔。然后当伯明翰逐渐扩张进来时，这就成了夏尔的浩劫。没错。伯明翰在托尔金还是个男孩、然后是个少年的那个时刻，将其整个吞噬了。
The sort of tentacles of suburbia. Mordor. Edwardian. Yeah. Edwardian developers are swallowing it all up. But when Tolkien is 12, so he's lost his father in South Africa. And then when he is 12, his mother dies. She's a diabetic. And in those days,
郊区化的触角。魔多。爱德华时期。对。爱德华时期的开发商正在把这一切都吞噬掉。但是当托尔金12岁时，他在南非失去了父亲。然后当他12岁时，他的母亲去世了。她患有糖尿病，而在那个时代，
diabetics with her particular kind of diabetes didn't generally live beyond their mid-30s and she doesn't so she dies a priest there's a catholic priest who's very close to the family because of course they're catholics it's very close to the family he arranges for the two tolkien boys to go and live with an aunt in the center of birmingham basically so if anyone's been in from the centerire to the middle of the door they live very close in edge baston very close to what is now if you've ever driven through birmingham this big roundabout called the five ways roundabout cricket ground of course yeah well i don't think tolkien was a great cricketer he's a rugby man actually he's a rugby player um so they go and live there and
患有她这种特定糖尿病的人通常活不到三十岁中期，而她也没有撑过去，所以她去世了。有一位天主教神父与这个家庭非常亲密，因为他们当然是天主教徒，他与这个家庭关系非常密切，他安排这两个托尔金男孩去和伯明翰市中心的一个姑妈住在一起，基本上——所以如果有人从市中心去过伯明翰中部，他们住得离埃德巴斯顿非常近，非常靠近现在——如果你曾开车穿过伯明翰——这个叫“五路”的大转盘，当然还有板球场，是的，嗯，我不认为托尔金是个伟大的板球运动员，他其实是个橄榄球迷，他是个橄榄球员——嗯，所以他们去那里住，然后
they look out and he looks out of his window and there's factories and there's warehouses and shops and stuff and you can absolutely see where the nostalgia comes from where the sense of a sort of lost paradise where the sort of horror at industry and urbanism and modernity all of that is woven into the story of this kind of boy well because when i read lord of the rings as a you know when i was young i all of none of, none of this, I missed it all, but now you read it and you completely see that it's one of the great novels. It's one of the great anti-urban novels. It's one of the, it's,
他们往外看，他向窗外望去，到处都是工厂、仓库和商店之类的东西，你绝对能看出这种乡愁是从哪里来的，那种对失去的天堂的感觉，那种对工业、城市化和现代性的恐惧——所有这些都交织在这个男孩的故事中。因为当我年轻的时候读《指环王》，我所有这些……没有一样，没有一样，我全错过了，但现在你再去读，你完全会发现这是一部伟大的小说。它是最伟大的反城市小说之一。它是，
it's, it's, it's, it's a very green novel. It is. And that, that's a theme that I think people never, never noticed until probably the seventies. It's one of the great portrayals of the impacts of industrialization.
它，它，它，它是一部非常绿色的小说。确实如此。而这，我认为是一个直到大约七十年代才真正被人注意到的主题。它是对工业化影响的最伟大描绘之一。
It is. Absolutely. It is. Absolutely. It is. Absolutely it is. Absolutely it is. And it's not Mordor is industrial, isn't it? And then, of course, the scouring of the Shire scene at the end of the Lord of the Rings. But Saruman is the key figure. He is, yeah, because he's fascinated by it. He's ingenious, isn't he? He's always creating
确实如此。绝对是的。确实如此。绝对是的。确实如此。绝对是的。绝对是的。而且魔多不是很工业化吗？然后，当然，还有《指环王》结尾处肃清夏尔的场景。但萨鲁曼是关键人物。是的，因为他对此着迷。他很有灵气，不是吗？他总是在创造
machines. Engines and fire and machines. Absolutely. And I know there were some people... Eugenics and all kinds of... There were some people listening to this who hate Tolkien and hate the lord of the rings and hate the fantasy genre and that i think is completely fair enough i think there's no reason why you should like it but even if you don't like it it does still matter because it is a brilliant mirror to the concerns of the 20th century and the fact that so many millions of people did like it tells you something about its power. But also, I would say, a mirror held up to the concerns of Catholics and Christians more generally in the 12th century. Tell us a ton.
机器。引擎、火焰和机器。绝对是的。而且我知道有些人……优生学和各种各样的……听这个节目的人中有些讨厌托尔金、讨厌《指环王》、讨厌奇幻流派的人，我认为这完全合情合理，我认为你没有任何理由必须喜欢它。但即使你不喜欢它，它依然很重要，因为它是反映20世纪关切的一面绝佳镜子，数以百万计的人喜欢它这一事实本身就说明了它的力量。但同时，我认为，这也是一面折射出12世纪天主教徒和基督徒更广泛关切的镜子。告诉了我们很多。
Go on. I'll give you a little bit of leeway. All I would say. So I wrote about Tolkien. By the way, just so the listeners know, as he's saying all I would say, he's kind of gearing up. I get the sense of this cross on which paper he's him he's going to start reading no no no i'm i'm not but the justification that i had so i i included him in a chapter that was basically about the first world war the rise of fascism and yes i remember it very good and i thought can you know it's lord
说吧。我给你一点回旋的余地。我只想说。所以我写过关于托尔金的文章。顺便说一下，为了让听众知道，当他说“我只想说”时，他有点在做准备。我感觉到他正准备开始宣读……不，不，不，我不是。但我这样做的理由是——所以我在一章中把他写进去了，那一章主要关于第一次世界大战、法西斯主义的兴起，是的，我记得，非常好，我想，你知道的，《指环》
of the rings sufficient to bear the weight that it's it you know i'm going to impose on its shoulders i think it is for kind of complex reasons to do with Tolkien's attitude to to the Jews, to to the Nazis, to the fire bombings that the RAF carried out in in Germany. Actually, you know, Tolkien said Lord of the Rings is not an allegory. And so people have always been slightly nervous about weaving it into the events of the 20th century. But he'd fought in the in the trenches at the Somme. His son flew planes over occupied Germany. So he was very, very intimately involved in that. argue that actually Lord of the Rings far more than 1984 actually is the great novel written about the horrors of the 20th century. And the reason that I say that is that even more
《指环王》是否足以承受我要强加在它肩上的重量？我认为是的，这出于一些复杂的原因，与托尔金对犹太人、对纳粹、对英国皇家空军在德国进行的轰炸的态度有关。实际上，你知道，托尔金说过《指环王》不是寓言。因此人们一直对把它编织进20世纪的事件中感到有点不安。但他曾在索姆河的战壕里战斗过。他的儿子曾在被占领的德国上空驾驶飞机。所以他非常、非常亲密地参与其中。有人会认为，实际上《指环王》比《1984》更堪称描写20世纪恐怖的伟大小说。我之所以这么说，是因为甚至比
than 1984, it's a colossal popular success. It's the best-selling novel of the 20th century. And I would argue that one of the, I think a key reason for its popularity is that it gives a people, you know, people who are suspicion of Christian orthodoxy, suspicious of Christian scripture, suspicious of Christian belief, a chance to experience what it is about Christianity that has made it so successful and so appealing and so powerful. Because in a sense, Lord of the Rings is the last great popular Christian work. Because of the distrust of power, of strength, because of the celebration of smallness, and all of those kinds of things. And also, Tom, there was this key moment. So for people who do know Lord of the Rings,
《1984》更甚，它是一部巨大的畅销书。它是20世纪最畅销的小说。我认为它之所以如此受欢迎的一个关键原因在于，它让那些对基督教正统心存疑虑、对基督教经文心存疑虑、对基督教信仰心存疑虑的人们，有机会体验到基督教究竟有何特质，才使得它如此成功、如此迷人且如此强大。因为从某种意义上说，\《指环王》\是最后一部伟大的流行基督教作品。因为对权力和力量的不信任，因为对渺小的赞美，以及所有这些东西。而且，汤姆，当时有一个关键时刻。所以对于那些了解《指环王》的人来说，
if you hate the Lord of the Rings, you've probably switched off already, let's be honest. But if you know the Lord of the Rings, you will know that at the end of the book, Frodo does not destroy the ring he claims it for his own he's weak he is human and fallible and then there's this kind of moment that tolkien himself basically says in his letters is the kind of intervention of divine grace because he has forgiven he is they have should be merciful to golem and they could have killed Gollum but they didn't they were merciful to Gollum and of course that's the moment that Gollum he sort of leaps up
如果你讨厌《指环王》，你可能已经关掉不听了，老实说。但如果你了解《指环王》，你就会知道在书的结尾，弗罗多并没有摧毁魔戒，而是把它据为己有。他是软弱的、是有人性和弱点的。然后有一个这样的时刻，托尔金本人基本上在信件中说，这是神圣恩典的一种介入，因为他曾原谅过、他们本应该对咕噜仁慈，他们本可以杀了咕噜，但他们没有，他们对咕噜保持了仁慈。当然，就在那一刻，咕噜他跳了起来，
and he bites Frodo's ring off and then he falls in. Spoiler alert. Well I mean no one's going to be listening to it. Then he falls in and it's through, what is it fate? I mean I think there's some line that Gandalf says maybe it was meant to happen. So you know, all this.
他咬掉了弗罗多戴着魔戒的手指，然后掉了进去。剧透警告。嗯，我的意思是反正也没人会听。然后他掉了进去，是通过……什么？命运吗？我的意思是我想甘道夫说过某句台词，也许这就是命中注定。所以，你知道，诸如此类。
So you know the date on which that happens? Oh, I do know. I've forgotten what it is. It's got some significance. It does. So it's the 25th of March, which is traditionally the date of both the crucifixion and the incarnation. Oh, right.
所以你知道发生这件事的日期吗？哦，我知道。我忘了是什么了。它有什么重大意义。确实有。那是3月25日，传统上这一天既是耶稣受难日，也是道成肉身之日。哦，对。
Very good. And so you're talking about a profoundly significant date. And in general, the overt Christian illusions are minimal. You know, there are no gods at all in Lord of the Rings. But at this point, he does bring it in. And I think it's, you know, it's incredibly significant. Anyway, we mustn't, I don't think that we should, we should talk much more about this because we're saving up an episode on Tolkien.
非常好。所以你说的是一个具有深远意义的日期。总的来说，显而易见的基督教隐喻是极少的。你知道，《指环王》里根本没有神。但在这一点上，他的确引入了这一点。而且我认为，你知道，这具有极其重大的意义。无论如何，我们绝不能——我认为我们不应该再多谈这个了，因为我们要把关于托尔金的一整期节目留到后面。
We've got lots to talk about. Episodes, we're saving up an episode on Tolkien. We've got lots to talk about. Episodes, plural, lined up on Tolkien later on. So that will woo the Catholics back. Yeah, we've got the Catholics back. We've still got the Protestants on side. Tomorrow we're going to make a bid for the existentialists and the abolitionists, I think, aren't we? Yes, yes, yes.
我们有很多要谈的。节目，复数形式，后面还会安排关于托尔金的节目。所以这会把天主教徒重新吸引回来。是的，我们把天主教徒吸引回来了。我们依然争取到了新教徒的支持。明天我们要为存在主义者和废奴主义者争取支持，我想，对吧？是的，是的，是的。
So we're basically appealing to every part of the community so an existentialist abolitionist themed uh special tomorrow we will see you then bye bye thanks for listening to the rest is history. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以我们基本上在呼吁社区的每一个群体，因此明天会有一个以存在主义者和废奴主义者为主题的特别节目，我们到时见，拜拜。感谢收听《历史的剩余》。想要收听独家节目、抢先体验、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。